να μεγαλώνουνς πουδζουν ξαφνικά όλα τα πράγματα που θεωρίς δεδομένα αλλάζουν αλλά πό την αρχή
ήξέρω ότι ήταν μονόδρομος ότι έπρεπε να το αντιμετωπίσω να κάνω ότητον το καλύτερο δυνατό
για να μπορέσων να το ξεπεράσω και γεννικά στο πως αντιμετωπίζω τα πράγματα και ση
τουλειά μου και ως επίτροπος είναι ότι βλέπω το ποτήρι μισό γιεματο μείναι πολύ δύσκολο
να το δομίσοάδειο έρχονται αναποδιές δεν διαγνωστικά μια φορά είχα και υποτροπές αλλά ι πεντξει
συνέβηκε ξανάπό την αρχή ξανάμπροστα και με έκανε να είμαι ακόμη πιο έτσι να θέλω
ακόμη περιπερισσότερο να εκδιεκδικήσου για τους υπόλι πους ασθενείς έχοντας περασδι αυτή την εμπιρία και
το θεωρό μεγάλον προνόμειο τεράσειο προνόμει ότο ότι μουδώθηκε αυτή ευκαιρία να εργαστώ και να
προσφέρωυ σε ευρωπαϊκό επίπεδο πια ν αλλάξω τα δεδομένα για τα θέματα που αφορούν τους
καρκοινοπαθείς και τις οικογένειες τους σε ευρωπαϊκό επίπεδο ορεία με τις ρώσεις φυγούρες κάπου διάβαζα
τελευταίωσε ότι ίπατε ότι στην πρώ την μπορεα με τις ρώσις φυγούρες σαστανδέκατε καμένα κοπέλε
πως μιωθίστελα κριακήδου χρόνια μετά που απότε είναι εμπορεία με τις ρώσες φυγουρες είναι να
ποτάμι να αγάπης κυριολεκτικά στελα κύριακή δου κάθε φορά που είναι υπορία με τις ρώς
φυγουρες νιώθει άγχος πρώτο άγχος αν θα βρέξει δεύτερο άγχος ανθαρθεικόσμος μισώς για τη θυμάστε
εκείνο την πρώτη μέρα που ήτατην πρώτη μέρα που θυμάμε όταν είπα μάλιστα το είχα
πειτότε στο σύζυγο μου ότι θα θα προσπαθήσω να κάω ένα κάλεσμα να μαζευτούμε κάποιες
γυναίκες με εμπυρία μαζί